e us open in hawaii one sempre difficile
trovare entro nuove belle a tutti i
ragazzi pervenute quest'anno uffici non
sono fa vj l'avrete già detto dal titolo
quindi inutile che faccio l'effetto
sorpresa di sto gran cazzo perché tanto
sapete già tutti che cosa si tratta va a
fan culo ai titoli di youtube e siamo
qui oggi ragazzi appunto perla andare a
vedere questa top ten dei video più
belli che ho fatto secondo voi andandoli
a commentare insieme per vedere che cosa
è uscito fuori sincerissimo non mi
aspettavo questi titoli mai nella vita
eppure eppure la top ten di video di far
ejei secondo il grande pubblico del web
e parte con il decimo posto che è fatto
ultima volta per decretare i posti che
era molto figo a quella transizione
spendiamo rivedere devo anche copiare i
miei video i miei stessi video perché
non mi ricordo come l'avevo fatti e
blaine ha detto i nomi in inglese poi ok
figata number two blog a los angeles dei
tre blog che ho fatto anzi dei quattro
anzi dei cinque break
questo è surreale il video più visto di
los angeles ed è bellissimo secondo me
perché ci sono dei punti in cui tipo
questo questo era bellissimo ragazzo da
parte qua mi quando quando ero lì mi
dovevo tenere per non ridere st parte va
fatto per scassare la parte del
[ __ ] è bellissimo
due ragazzi questo è questa è delle
scene dei blog credono me ne sia mai
uscita una più bella di questa perché il
minio di ricerca non mi trova e va poi a
parte dove mi faccio arrestare credo
anche se la parte dell'eni faccia
restare non si vede quanto figata cosa
comunque questa questo viaggio senza è
stato uno dei più belli in assoluto la
ratio vari j da piccolo mi è capitato
più volte di fare delle regioni di me da
bambino da 3 milioni di views ci ha pure
questo 3 milioni di views li vale solo
mio padre che ai capelli quindi quando
perdere i capelli sarà tragica la situa
sanremo sanremo sanremo sarebbe trovare
i core da vaste roma migliaia
beh quella è esageratamente una pila
lorenzo bravo la bellissima
vabbè allora for happy day
va bene dai con me merita la nona
posizione con ero piccolo mio padre mi
facevo un sacco di video con la
videocamera già sapeva che erano che
sarei diventato youtube è il resto non
so come cazzo faccia e sarà l'ottavo
posto scrive la hus nella vita reale
tre anni fa se dicevo le vie grigi
grazie frank matano che compare nelle
pubblicità che mi fa piacere ma ha
bisogno di compagnia
troppo facile recitazione fratello
recitazione fratello sicuramente la
grande farai un film questo è scritto
nella sala ok miglior amico cazzo per
ora bello eh
perfetto effetti speciali spielberg
checa chi cazzo è spielberg c'erano e io
ora dobbiamo stronzate che hanno
doppiato l'inizio maurizio valente che
ha doppiato non ha raddoppiato un cazzo
però ha fatto tutto il montaggio però ci
siamo divertiti un sacco era bellissimo
cioè era tutto bello tranne la mia
recitazione per il resto i ragazzi hanno
fatto un lavoro della madonna ma borse
bene the sims alla ragazzi fa vj non sa
come fare lo youtuber perché the sims ho
fatto ho fatto solo due episodi che sono
stati in questi due primo episodio va
fatto 3 milioni e passa di views il
secondo episodio ha fatto quasi 3
milioni di virus che sono tantissime e
poi non l'ho più continuato perché se
facciamo così tante visione lo
continuato perché non so fare lo youtube
è una famiglia fantastica bellissimo
3.200.000 avviso sta roba solo perché
avevo fatto shrek all'inzio scommetto
quello che volete porterà bene quanta la
shayk davvero sto qua come cazzo ho
fatto a farlo così bene se non è
meritato il settimo posto dopo questa
roba non so io che cosa lo merita
la borsa e vi e v e viii non ha ancora
capito come cazzo si dice la parte di e
vie che vi è piaciuta di più in assoluto
è stata quella di hunger games denti ma
l'hai visto hunger games
qual è il tuo personaggio preferito il
mio è vita il tuo e guarda c'è anche
edward in hunger games
questa è stata la parte la parte che vi
è piaciuta apparentemente di più perché
tutti quanti mela menate ancora questo
hunger games number five o questo questo
era un video questo questo è un video ma
vivido vero fatto registrato in 20
minuti editato in ancora meno ma è un
video email fanno quiz su falli j o fa
vj fa qui sui mezzi tutte e due sono
andati a bomba bra bra perfetto quello
che devo dire che l'inizio vale il video
era questo c'è da che cosa bisogna
vedere dopo basta va bene così semplice
fa vi sono nella vasca e ci sono 100mila
ladri che bellissimo vi era giunto
cittadina like veramente 100.000 e 137
laiche grazie che non avete cagato per
una volta number four su motori dreams
sui motori dreams ragazzi era allora
dissi vi svelo sta roba io all'inizio
sapete che tutte le domeniche shepis
quasi tutte le domeniche all'inizio
quando aperto il canale volevo far sì
che il sabato uscisse un blog e che la
domenica uscisse happy with però non
volevo far uscire tutte le domeniche
primis volevo alternarlo con un'altra
serie e questa serie è in realtà e su
motori trims volevo fare quindi uscire
un episodio di happy vis è un episodio
di fumatori dreams alternandoli di
settimana in settimana poi in realtà
questa cosa non è andata a buon fine
perché su motori dreams a differenza di
happy with dopo un po diventa ripetitivo
quindi non andava più bene e quindi ho
fatto solo è più visto quanto sono
contento di questa cosa per chi non
c'era nel periodo di su motori dei
ragazzi vi siete persi una delle cose
più famiglie dell'abitato della vita
cazzo era bellissima materia è arrivato
solo quarto ma meritava il podio secondo
me suonatori va bene anche qui hanno
fatto anche google goggles che era un
gioco di calcio brutti se non ho fatto
da
adesso si chiede a caso quanto era bello
quanto erano bellissimi giochi signori i
signori siamo arrivati al podio che
merita la vita credo perché state per
vedere dei titoli che non mi aspettavo
mai nella vita neanch'io number five
ejei immagina vi spiego un secondo che
cosa è successo e le fan hanno scritto
delle storie su di me erotiche
ok questa cosa come se non facesse
abbastanza ridere ci ho fatto anche dei
video sopra che si chiamano appunto
immagina se non l'avete presente di che
cosa si tratta andiamo subito a vedere
che accompagna alla porta e vi salutate
ma lui ti bacia è che ti sbatte e si
sono fatte sul letto a smettere ma voi
sapete che a voi sapete il disagio nel
leggere sta roba per me e leggere che
una ragazza di probabilmente 14 anni
quattordici anni 14 anni leggere che una
ragazza di quell'età scrive queste cose
su di me mi sento sporco mi sento come
se come se mi dovessi entrare la polizia
in casa mi sento proprio p violato
nell'intimo bruttissima questa cosa
della mia timidezza peggiora tutto sto
casino quindi lasciamo perdere
il secondo video più bello del canale va
vj versus ragno gigante questo video è
stato talmente visto che minchia per chi
non lo sapesse facesse a breve
introduzione sono aracnofobia che cosa
vuol dire anacna fobico velico paura dei
ragni ma non ho semplicemente paura io
ho la fobia non è tanto la pa parte la
paura che più che si vede una tarantola
vicino un po sicari addosso ma io ho
proprio la fobia c'è nel senso
è veramente pesante sta roba e quindi
quando mi era capito perché in quella
casa dove abitavo prima questa
bellissima casa nella quale ho dei
ricordi stupendi mi era capitato di
vedere sto ragno gigante che anche solo
a rivedere il video io non riesco mi fa
schifo
devo documentare questa cosa è inchiesta
mani a chi national geographic li vedi
questi grossi saltiamo subito al punto
nel quale ho tentato di ammazzarlo crepa
sardo morto morto
magari morto morto si muove
porca [ __ ] [ __ ] tutto è morta grossa
quanto una bottiglia rotto solo ormai
richiamo ricordò così grosso mentawai
terry
[Musica]
barbie dream house party di tanto in
tanto mi guardo attorno e cerco di
capire più o meno
qual è il percorso che ho fatto per
arrivare fino a qua ragazzi siamo
arrivati a 3 milioni e 300mila iscritti
più o meno che un traguardo incredibile
andando incontro alle esigenze dei miei
scritti che mi chiedono di fare dei
video giochi per il mio canale che poi
io registro e porto sul mio canale ma
come cazzo si fa a mettere barbie dream
house party primo come cazzo avete
votato barbie dream house party come
video più bello del mio canale da quando
faccio video poi volete dirmi che il
podio dei miei video è detenuto da
barbie dream house party tra i primi
video che anzi il video più visualizzato
di barbie non era anche questo ma è
questo grazie frank matano però la lotta
frank matano non mi ha tartassato il
cazzo con la pubblicità all'inizio dei
vito ma ero quasi contento di vedere lui
piuttosto che sono fa vj e la gestiamo
su barbie
[Musica]
sì
va bene ragazzine che possono includere
chi con questo video a quanto lasciamo
perdere però sono stato molto stupito di
vedere che la vostra top era molto
diversa dalla mia ma tantissimo per
un'altra roba
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
cose se vi è piaciuta sull'argomento è
un mi piace anche ai vari social che
come nei video totale descrizione sono
saliti di 7 cv tivano prossimo video
bella ragazzi e speriamo di non
incontrare altri ragni che porca [ __ ]
è stato guarda ragazzi